good morning uh everybody and thanks to
the organizers for the invitation I
think the weather was uh in a conspiracy
against this meeting it's still trying
with the cold weather so it's very nice
to be here anyhow um let me start with a
quote on water which uh you can read
water mingles with every kind of natural
phenomenon and more than one might
imagine it has also mingled with the
particular Destiny of mankind this is of
course about the the past about the
history of civilization but the same
could probably be said about the future
in terms of um climate change and and
water resources and my talk today will
relate to two diseases that are very
closely related to to water waterbor
diseases such as colera and Vector born
diseases
such as uh malaria and I will focus on
climate variability rather than climate
change per se despite the title of this
uh of this Symposium and in part this
choice is because um through the studies
of retrospective effects of climate
variability at seasonal interanal time
scales we can hope to understand how
climate drives epidemiology and then
extrapolate into the future and also as
emphasizing in the in the previous talk
it is through change in the variability
itself that we expect climate change to
act and so so that is at least in part
to act and and um examples are changes
in the magnitude and frequencies of
floods and drugs droughts for
example now the following two slides
illustrate some retrospective patterns
uh with typical patterns of variability
for these diseases in places where we
have highly seasonal environments for
colera in Bangladesh from a rural area
south of Dhaka this uh time series is
meant to to show that u in addition to
variability we have pronounced variation
in uh the
interanal um uh size of outbreaks of
colera and the same for malaria in
semiarid regions uh the the red curve
shows a Time series of retro
retrospective cases this is in Northwest
India uh and you can see by eye some
correspondence to the rainfall which is
the limiting resource here for the the
mosquitoes now these are two cases of um
low transmission regions because of
these very highly seasonal environments
on average we have low transmission
regions and I'll return to that later
but it is in part in these regions that
we expect the high response to to
climate because of the limiting
effects of either rainfall or
temperatures in other
contexts and thinking about the future I
thought it would be interesting for this
for this meeting to consider uh the
effect of climate forcing in the context
of what we can call human dominated
environments for example large Urban
environments of the in uh large cities
of the developing world and also rural
regions with land use change uh that
underlies development now in the recent
uh literature in malaria we have seen
the view that uh perhaps we should not
worry so much about climate change and
um Vector born diseases because it will
be the effects will be negligible
compared to socioeconomic development in
the next 100 years and i' like with two
case studies here today hopefully to
emphasize that uh we need to focus a
little bit more on the interaction of
climate forcing with uh that type of
with socioeconomic issues so so the the
particular um examples I like to give
today come from retrospective studies of
Colora Dynamics in Bangladesh I will
start with a large scale picture of
associations with climate variable
climate variables and then zoom in into
the spal spatial temporal Dynamics
within the city of Dhaka for malaria I
will also um start with a sort of large
scale picture of some associations with
climate again for malaria in an arid
semiarid region of Northwest India and
mve to higher spatial resolutions in a
regional gradient of irrigation based
development so uh this is just uh one
result from a suite of uh analysis that
show uh good associations between the
Dynamics of colola in Bangladesh and the
El Nino Southern
oscillation what this map shows this is
in fact a map of uh correlations where
we take the average cases every year
post Monsoon this is the the second peak
of cola and we correlated with every
grid point of uh C surface temperature
global grid product and the colors just
show the the correlations the black
lines shows the shows the the regions
above the
90% uh confidence and you can see this
this region in particular of positive
correlation so that uh warming of this
part of the ocean in December January
February uh is Then followed 9 months
later by uh higher peaks of colera the
same can be seen more or less with a
less uh pronounced pattern for the city
of Dhaka and I'll return to that later
so it is interesting that of course this
region corresponds to the region that
warms during the elos and if we uh we
can ask whether that's just a
correlation or whether there is a
physical basis for this teleconnection
our climate collaborators have published
a number of papers that you cannot see
because it's down here on U on numerical
um climate simulations showing the
linkage between changes in that region
of the Pacific
and what changes regionally over
Bangladesh and this has identified
enhanced precipitation as one of the
possible linkages uh that's these
results are in models but that
corresponds also to uh what we see in
precipitation anomalies in ears that uh
ELO ears so so there is a physical basis
for that and and based on these results
and and others we have hypothesized that
it is through flooding and the breakdown
of sanitary conditions that this ELO
teleconnection is acting on colera an
alternative set of mechanisms more
closely related to the Ecology of the
pathogen has been proposed by also Rita
cwell and and and her colleagues and
this has a lot to do with uh the
survival of the pathogen outside the the
human host in aquatic environments uh
with focus on the effect of temperature
Plankton blooms and another another
mechanisms very closely connected to the
Ecology of the pathogen this is
interesting because in these
environments you find the pathogen in in
the same um in the water this uh disease
transmits to transmits through a FAL
oral route these are open latrines and
this is a fisherman and the situation
gets worse in a city like Dhaka where a
large fraction of the population has no
no access to clean water now we did a
lot of uh modeling on this
um trying to capture the patterns in
this time series with more detail
epidemiological mods and then uh we were
uh we said well let's get the data for
the city of Dhaka not for the rural
regions and repeat something like this
but because this is a very different
environment than the rural one I just
showed you we uh we had to change a
little bit how we did it and this is H
this is from a recently published uh
paper in particular by my post dog
Robert rer but when we got got the data
we were very happy because we said can
we have the data resolved especially
within the city so these are uh tanas
districts within the within the city of
Dhaka very quickly let me see if I can
do this
um yeah maybe I can do this no this is
funny because we tested it uh 10 minutes
ago it doesn't matter I'll tell you what
this is
anyhow this is a mystery it did play a
few minutes ago so what you were meant
to see and what we saw when we got this
and we're so happy to have spatially
resolved data was that first of all the
the Dynamics were extremely stochastic
with places you have no cases then you
get cases so that was a problem because
our previous malls uh couldn't handle
that that too well and then you would
have seen if you looked at this for a
long time that when you have PS uh in
the aggregated prevalence of the disease
there was a suggestion that the core of
the city surrounded by that dark line
was responded uh more intensive
intensively and differentially with
respect to the rest of the city so we
built a different type of Mall because
of the
stochasticity um of this data and to
test whether we had to consider the SE
that there was heterogenity within the
city in the response and one main
motivation here is that of course we
think of climate foring at Regional
scales uh so we generally aggregate the
data but i' like to show you uh that
that maybe a problem and and there is a
question of the scales at which the
susceptibility of the human population
responds so the details of them all do
not matter what we did was to classify
the disease levels into three levels and
then do a model that essentially says if
you are in uh the state of no color or
High color medium col what's your
probability of moving into another state
and so we have this uh this uh Matrix of
transition probabilities which we Fe
from the data and then we can what we
did in the mod is to consider first that
we could have two groups of districts
with different probabilities also that
the probabilities were affected by Eno
and that uh it matter whether your
neighbors had a a high case of high
situation for color Etc because these Ms
are nested you can actually feed them
and with some likelihood test uh tell
whether the more complicated m is um is
actually doing better or not this here
shows for example the the basic
probabilities Modified by the C surface
temperature anomaly uh which in in this
case can take uh nonlinear uh form and
then we fitted these molds and without
going into the details what I wanted to
show you is that there is very strong
statistic statistical support for these
two groups of the city in fact if we
didn't separate uh the the Dynamics in
the two places we couldn't fit the data
there is also very interestingly support
for an interaction between uh climate
forcing and spatial
heterogeneity so for example the effect
of Eno is significantly different
between the two groups and also uh this
is the case for flooding and the Eno
effects effect has this lag that is
consistent with what we had seen before
now we use this model then to ask about
prediction short-term prediction by
removing one year at a time which is not
ideal but it's what we can do with this
kind of data and I I'm just showing here
the data in Black the predictions are in
in blue and then if you look in
particular at two ELO years we can sort
of have a probability of seeing uh cases
above the for example the
75% uh percentile of the data this is
the prediction the observation and in
these cases we would have predicted 99%
chance of having an out a very large
outbreak and the same almost for May
2003 so this is just to show that this
model has some predictive
ability now you can ask what is
different between the two parts of the
city we don't have very good data for
this I must confess F but I wanted to
show you that there are um differences
in socioeconomic indicators for example
the density in the city and this is uh
this is not a mistake in the zeros this
is 100,000 people for by kilometer
square and this here shows the the
concentration of the poorest type of
housing so some suggestion that this
connects to uh what we to sort of human
factors we can also ask about the
flooding in the city something that we
are looking at right now but to
summarize this part of the talk uh I
have shown that uh well in this work and
and previously that there is a strong
connection to Eno and flooding for the
postmonsoon colera outbreak and that
this effect of Elin is partly through
precipitation and Associated flooding we
can therefore ask what will happen with
climate change in particular in terms of
the uh floods floods frequency and
intensity uh but that this population
susceptibility shows pronounced
Geographic variation within a city such
as Dhaka with a part of the city really
acting as a susceptible core and we have
to ask what uh in these large cities as
they develop we have this is a city with
around 15 million people that is thought
to um double very quickly in the next
decades so Urban population growth
access to clean water and sanitation is
key here clearly from what we what we
have seen and you can say well for those
of you that know the history of col the
discovery of his waterborne transmission
this is Jon Snow Revisited JN snow was
the father of geography and epidemiology
who identified the pump in London the
streets where uh the the disease the
origin of the the disease was related to
this pump a wonderful book on this The
History of Science well this is JN snow
Revisited but in the context of climate
forcing an Omega city of the developing
world and my feeling is that if we uh
ignore this type of variation in
susceptibility in the future uh our MS
may not do as well you can also say well
this is just colera and this is a slide
meant to emphasize that maybe we should
do some comparative uh analysis for
different groups of diseases this is
another diarrheal disease chosis with a
different ecology different transmission
pathway uh as far as I know the
bacterium that causes chosis does not
survive uh in the in the Aquatic
environment in the way that vibrio does
it transmits through water and food much
more directly uh if I ask you which of
these Maps is Cola which one is shig
chosis in this case she caused by Shiga
Flex ner you wouldn't be able to tell
and the same applies to Dhaka the the
point I'm making is that there may be uh
systemic U um behaviors of groups of
diseases Within These environments that
are very similar let me change G change
gears to a different disease and um a
bit the uh the opposite pattern this is
a very dry area in Northwest India these
are the the states of Gujarat and R and
rajastan for which we have retrospective
data at the level of districts and um
this is the District of cat I I'll focus
on these these are some districts in
rajastan and then I'm going to move in
this direction and down in a gradient
that has higher irrigation and higher
development these are the data I showed
you before for one of the districts this
is is catch reported cases from 19 well
this is 20 years and not surprisingly
this is a desert this disease is
transmitted by mosquitoes if I uh look
at accumulated rainfall in previous six
months and cases you see this type of
threshold Behavior with a lot of noise
and if we look in the same way as we did
before at um what happens in the um in
the o that may be of interest to us to
have longer lead times for prediction
for example we were surprised by this
pattern where uh we are now taking the
cases in the peaks of malaria and
correlating them correlating them with
the the whole uh map of U ssts SE
surface temperatures and we were looking
to find something perhaps here because
of the the history of uh relationships
between Enos and Eno and the monsoons uh
which of course has changed over in in
uh in over decades and we we were
somewhat surprised by finding this
negative correlation with the tropical
South Atlantic uh that was a bit of a
surprise and of course some people my
climate colleagues said No No this must
be wrong it must just be um perhaps it
has no physical basis some sort of
Association anyhow it was interesting
there was a bit of literature about
Connections of this region with the
monsoons but I'm showing you this
because the point is the link with
rainfall is strong enough to tell you
something about climate and in fact um
if you look at the correlation between
disease and rainfall not surprisingly
it's a regional uh you see this Regional
effect over India but this Sim this map
that is somewhat similar is the result
of some numerical climate simulations in
which the conditions in the trop
tropical South Atlantic are fixed uh to
study what is their effect over India
and we have this uh relationship with
increased rainfall so this is from a
paper that is impressed and suggests
that there is this link between the
Atlantic and uh rainfall and therefore
malaria and we have used then models um
that incorporate and I'm not going to
describe this in it's a simple
epidemiological mod of transmission in
which the force of infection is a fun is
a function of rins and anyhow we feed
these molds and we can um basically test
Ms with rainfall without rainfall
compare them to each other statistically
just by I and and you would expect that
the one with rainfall does better but
I'm showing you this because it's a
strong relationship these are not fits
the data again are here in red I don't
know why this disappears The the
simulations without uh the the the
median of many stochastic simulations
are shown here in black and then the
uncertainty in Gray and you can see uh
these are simulations from estimated
initial conditions for 20 years and we
capture a fair fair amount of the
variability now all this will not
surprise you after all these are semi
regions but what I think is interesting
is to us well when we are in a district
like this that has been very very
unmodified by humans and we go to a
place like the one in the left that's
the District of kada lots of Agriculture
uh supported by higher Min RS but also
irrigation and we did compare then a
gradient in uh we can rank these
districts in terms of their uh
irrigation levels and what is
interesting here is to see through these
Maps in the different districts from
least aggregated to more aggregated you
have here the correlations for different
maps with uh with a remote sensing
variable that measures vegetation on the
ground and DVI and what I'm showing you
here is as you move in this direction
the the red uh the significant and high
correlations that we find regionally
disappear when we move to these District
so you can say well maybe
uh there is no no longer a link between
rainfall and
disease but if you look more carefully
at the at the time series you see an
interesting pattern of course uh the
problem with studying disease is that
people are interfering with your studies
all the time and that by the time you
understand something is no longer the
same so that's sometimes bad and
sometimes interesting here we have the
the cases in in red the rain in the
dotted line and this is data on the
degree of control to spraying mosquito
this is insecticide residual spraying
levels and you can almost get the sense
there was less control before but that
we have this this data from 1996 when
they intensified control and you can see
that they are doing fairly well here
High control low cases and now they get
a surprise this is one year with large
rainfall and a relaxation of control so
if you plot the population covered by by
spray versus the cases in the previous
two years you have this very nice
relationship which is in part the result
of a reactive policy that uses previous
cases to decide where to actually
intervene uh at some level if resources
are limited and simply from the the
perception of risk uh systems of control
risk respond and relax on sometime scale
and in this in this type of environment
when this is combined with high rigns
you can see these responses now if you
if you look even at higher spatial
resolutions you see very interesting
pattern I'm taking now this district and
and and the adjacent districts at the
higher spatial resolution of what is
called tcas uh these
subdistricts um for which we also have
cases from 1997 to to
2011 and very quickly I want to show you
some interesting patterns first of all
this is a map of regions that are
irrigated in uh this is from very
detailed remote sensing in
2009 this is a blind analysis that takes
the SpaceTime data and does some
grouping based on a mod U of uh of the
same kind that I showed show you for
Cola but interestingly you get two
groups that map very well this is one
group with diff U lower chera sorry
lower malaria and then the higher U
higher malaria here and so you have
these two groups that behave
differently more interesting to me is
that uh okay that was Irrigation in 2009
what if we look at how irrigation has
changed in the last decade unfortunately
we didn't have the data so we use a
trick that worked very well in these
regions if you look at ndvi vegetation
in January it reflects irrigation
because at that time obviously there is
no rain so that's that allows you to map
very well uh irrigation from a very
simple threshold in January so this is
the change in irrigation over a decade
and it is in this boundary region where
a canal has moved and it's not
officially open but people are using it
at Le at least from remote sensing we
can see it it is at the boundary of
these two groups that we see the highest
change in irrigation so you can ask well
what has happened to malaria and what
has happened to
control first you can see in this map if
we look uh true time and this is for the
first five years but the similar map
applies in the second if we say the
relative risk of malaria this is this is
normalized incidence relative to the
highest place the the highest risk is
found in that boundary so overall they
are uh bringing the disease down but
over that decade these regions with the
the the highest change in the landscape
are the the ones in the higher risk so
you can say well what about control
maybe they are not controlling well this
is where they are controlling the most
so what I'm showing here is a map again
relative to one of this uh IRS the
spraying of mosquitoes they are spraying
like crazy this is population cover
percent population cover these
subdistricts here are the ones with high
risk and high control where they are
covering of the order of 80% of the
population and that again everything is
going down slowly but this pattern
persists so in summary we have the
following situation this places here
have been irrigated for decades and they
have low risk they are in that sort of
sustainable low risk
situation why is another
discussion here we have very rainfall
driven Dynamics and in the middle we
have the irrigation change with the
malaria risk and high control this
defines therefore these regions of high
risk due to climate variability and
regions of uh in this kind of transition
regime that is not new in the literature
but what is new is that this can last
over a decade so this is over a decade
of trying to control something and uh
and essentially having these types of
Dynamics where you have unexpected
surprises so again these are not uh
these are not these are not stable
situations and they can revert to these
once you relax
control
so with these examples I tried to show
you that um the as we try to look into
the future of course we can always make
uh projections for for risk uniquely
based on the environment and that will
be valid but that uh there is also there
will be important intera interactions
with development that will be uh very
Dynamic and that uh cannot be ignore but
it does not mean that we are not going
to see effects of climate because of De
velopment I think uh that studying uh
Urban environments is important but also
taking advantage of regional
gradients where we have data for these
Regional
gradients and under seasonal forcing to
look at these different stages of
development and understand how they may
affect the effect of climate is
important and also that regions with
pronounced seasonality this regions that
we call in the case of malaria unstable
regions at the edge of the
distribution that have low transmission
and this very epidemic Dynamics those
are very important regions to look uh to
understand both the problems of
emergence but also the problem of
elimination as we move these systems
close to those boundaries we are going
to move them from uh more stable High uh
High rates to very Dynamic situations
with the this sort of more epidemic and
surprising Dynamics and I think these
these regions today which uh I showed
you for India in the case of deserts but
we can also consider in U in Africa for
example with altitude the limitation of
temperature um affecting the malaria
distribution in some of the Highland
regions uh in Africa uh those are also
interesting very important regions to
study today to have a picture of what we
happen happened with climate change and
I think Matt will talk about those
regions later I have to end but I I have
one slide on climate change because
because of the I am finishing uh so so I
meant I I mentioned comparisons of
groups of related diseases I I think we
don't do enough of this and it's
important because I think it can tell us
about Pathways of action of climate the
most important Pathways and first
personally I think that for the diarrhea
diseases it's really the human
susceptibility due to uh to sanitary
conditions Etc that matter so so uh as
long as we don't take care of that we
are going to see surises of climate but
then this comparisons of projections
with ensembles of Ms maybe we will hear
madin Thompson talk about this I know um
she is working on those types of
comparisons I wanted to show you that uh
when we do that this is a simple example
for Thailand in this is for Kenya
projected percent change in people
exposed to falum malaria in Kenya and
just to show you that if you look at
this line here you see different symbols
these are different mods in one case the
black dots are just from a statistical
model relating malaria to altitude as
aoxy for temperature the percent of the
population that will be affected by the
disease
change and the other colors come from
two places in the literature one is a
Time series M the other uses more
complicated suitability thresholds but
those projections are all uh very
similar and can give us some confidence
that we understand the problem I don't
think we we do enough of this and now to
finish I want to thank some of the
people that did the work my student
Andres vessa for the work in India also
uh my colleague U Aon King in the
department I mentioned my post do my
previous postdoc and then my colleagues
both from Bangladesh Muhammad yunus and
colleagues colleagues from India and
menoa from the London School of hygiene
and tropical medicine and finally
finally the funding in particular uh
Noah I know Julie has Julie traton who
is here has put a lot of effort in this
uh program in the past oceans and hell
that uh that has tried to fun a lot of
work at this interface with the
infectious diseases and climate thank
you very
much